because it really puts a brand new spin
on the same old zombies story it's about
a human survivor of a pandemic who's
looking for a cure to heal a new so
rabid like species of humans known as
the infected okay the key to that cure
is in locating the original patient zero
nests are about to find out there are
some surprises along the way
lazy gentleman let's bring out the
creative team of patient zero starting
with the director step on the bruising
Witzke coming right out on stage right
now they've been have ladies and
gentlemen
also joining Hammond straight right it
might be coming up to the side of the
stage run rankings camelot and doctor
the who clive standing is here and from
Game of Thrones John Bradley ladies and
gentlemen
Natalie Dormer manger and yes I wish you
mister
and yes the doctor is still Mao's Matt
Smith coming back
in the back do one of the extra exercise
going off and on again so I don't and I
could have been a cop skating to do with
you I'm afraid
Stuart you said zombies now it's been an
awesome movie this is the effective I am
aware I set a new twist on the zombies
story Natalie so I said it is infected
rabid like species absolutely and Stefan
I believe we actually have something to
show the folks here in college don't
what else are about to show you is
really super fresh we wrap literally
weeks ago so what you see here raw
material not looking good for you jump
Bradly not looking good spoiler alert
nice to know you're a lefty down here
usually a white Walker man he's infected
should be no problem what happened
dragonglass
did you practice your convulsing was
that something you worked at look good I
practiced okay families young families I
think it's really faster than that clip
is the relationship to your character
and Stanley Tucci's infected because it
feels fills me almost a little like
south of the Lambs almost in a way like
Hannibal and Clarice is this like a game
of cat and mouse you guys have my Wow
yeah yeah I guess this is a game of cat
and mouse and he's such a wonderful
actor Stanley so it's just sort of
wonderful spirits out around what's a
young he was yeah I was right fun to
outside yeah but it's very much me
trying to elicit information from the
day boy and not only what's you serve I
know you play Matt's wife in the film
you're sort of very well
are you a this movie no thanks no what's
your connection to what's your
connection to front of you making a
funny Santa doesn't love triangle um the
maps character Morgan is still in love
with memory of his wife is she alive
my machine used to be what we this is
like one of the questions of the movie
Gina is in love with Morgan but it's a
it's a complex situations the best way
of putting it but Gina is the
neurologist who has been designated to
basically cure the world it's a minor
specification you know it's easy enough
so yeah they're working as a team to
finally the war on the cure for the
rabies that is effective infecting these
infected
excellent plan how do you fit into all
this madness we friend-or-foe sir well I
couldn't not see some unhealthy
obsession with Gina and another
unhealthy obsession with alcohol and the
zoo's DVM the last point of call in the
US military he feels like he's mainly
stating these scientists where they're
trying to find patient zero which is
like trying to find a needle in a
haystack
and so there's two ways to finding a
needle in the haystack
you can either actually get all the
Haven a Nevada water and all the hate
comes to the top and none of the hay is
hot and you find a little needle well
you can do it not this way which is just
burn all the hay and that's kind of
doing it that means these one against
must have shoot first and ask questions
later I know you guys want ask some
questions so start lining up here in
just a minute we're gonna get to those
and now's the time to do a very short
window of time here but my clean here
the screenwriter ladies and gentlemen
just last year was camped out in line to
get into Hall H and now he's on the
stage how cool is that
you know not only when you wrote this
how do you strive to make this story
difference when we see it on the screen
a little bit but you know we have a lot
of you know monster stories and things
like that so how do you try and craft
something a little unique here well even
though the infected are definitely not
zombies the inspiration of this came
from seeing a zombie here in town a
couple years ago I saw a zombie giant
replica zombie smoking a cigarette and
and the image just stayed with me for
four months and and he came to the point
where I kept asking myself who was the
zombie
why was he smoking cigarette he had a
personality you know that guy he was an
individual you know purses lady that's
like my rap and so I started to do kind
of like invert those envelopes and when
you think us obviously moment morning
you know what if that was actually a
language that they were using to
communicate each other and so that's how
all right guys that anyone asked some
questions so let's go right here I was
going mad max' right my god
that's it all right
can you ask a question with that on or
not oh it sounds great
yeah no interference at all by what's
going on hi I'm Alison Joe fracture from
Canada mostly to see miss stormer I um I
was wondering these always having a line
of communication with the humans that
affect the dynamic sister not just these
- east train attack they're actually
have thoughts and communication if it's
like that I see that question I'm really
sorry
because because the zombies are able to
communicate with the humans how does
that affect the dynamics
since the not just - he's trying to
viciously attack any people
okay I'm gonna take this and I'm gonna
pass it to Matt so the really
interesting thing about all the books in
all the shows you guys love is that
every era or every tribe or every
historically every nation in the world
they always create the monsters that are
cathartic event their issues for their
culture of their time right I mean
infected a mud Mike correct me if I'm
wrong here but the infected are victims
of our modern age being bombarded by
social media 24/7 everything open the
idea is that rabies that harnesses your
adrenaline and all the the stress never
the mad fast pace that we live our 21st
century lives has been used to enrage
them and you because he's been so it was
thank you very much zombie eternity good
question I know I want to be infected so
I could hang out with Stanley Tucci yeah
I spend enough time with them on hunger
games I'm in love with diabetes yeah
I've given big a white Walker called me
that nicer life really it can't be can
you get to spend a lot of time with me
yeah Charlie Brown yeah
yeah I mean I don't think I'm that far
away from uninfected anyway I mean I
hate the most music and most of the
human race how do you think that this
movie differs from your traditional
zombie movie because we've obviously
seen a lot well imagine you've got
you've got adrenaline pulsing through
your veins all the time you hear these
stories about you know old women be able
to pick up cars of someone just because
they had to or whatever imagine being
like that all the time this is these are
people that can think they live they
breathe song and it's not these are the
undead these people have got a virus and
they fear they can figment for their own
thought but they've also got this
adrenaline pumping through them all the
time lately so being a train parkour
Runner and it's almost a calming it's
like it could almost be the next
evolution of the mankind and that's what
we're playing with in the films it's
this is this a race that people that
need to be stamped out and wiped up as
well there is its mother nature's way of
saying we're all of a virus with a virus
and this is her way of what wiping us
out and this is a new iteration of
mankind so you know they're not so easy
there's nothing to do with young people
chasing people down the street just
wanted to eat them and rip out their
hearts and then devour them these are
people that you know they want to stay
on the white house human race and they
want to take over the path and it feels
like judging by the cooks itself Stefan
you could have talked about this it
feels like there's a sense of
claustrophobia inist and that humans are
on these very confined corners trying to
survive that's from an element of the
terror as well yes definitely
the whole movie takes place in this I
think the other thing which is which is
sort of special with music so it's not
only what else is in the record
collection that loss got a monoid could
record that was actually one of the
things originally that really attracted
me to the script was a big music fan and
this you know they're fair about there
was a real presence of sort of good
rock'n'roll music in this building so
computers to see there's a period of you
you've had a better joke offer as well
maybe I think so it's all I'm fine is he
like in my hipster music stop what's
going on yeah you're gonna read books
cool but actually if I buy a lot of
vinyl as well myself I'm really into it
you get a full sound so you know
something in common
check out the soundtrack one more
question right there is you sir yeah
pretty much
what's Jurassic Park really good as well
yeah yeah they are gonna have strategic
people and attacks I think I think I
think that's one of the points in is
really you know we started going oh no
they're hunting us movie is like as a
client Whitney said imagine if the next
step in evolution Darwinism is that the
infected would take over the planet
they are the evolved next step for
mankind and yeah their intelligence
levels and what that means is something
that we explore
it's what I love about the movie as well
as it starts if we build up the tension
instead of in a world the key
mankind has gone underground that's how
bad the situation is we're trying to
find place in zero and it's like a
pressure cooker and the tension builds
and builds and builds but they're all
around and eventually if we're gonna
have a film full of conflict and drama
they're going to get in so one that
happens is sisters it's just intense and
you know we can't get away too much but
you know the way that these guys can
find their way down the rabbit hole
in 2016
you